[Music]
the gods gave us many gifts one day
you'll know them all this is where we
keep them it's beautiful
who would wield it only the fiercest
among us even could and that is not you
Diana
you will train her harder what the nanny
Amazon before her five times harder
penny time is harder never let your
guard down you expect the battles will
be fair until she is better than even
you but she must never know the truth
about what she is
[Applause]
what is this place who are you
it is our sacred duty to defend the
world right wherever you are you are in
more danger than you think
be careful Diana no one else will defend
the world that I must welcome to jolly
ol London he hears yeah it's not for
everybody
sit back or maybe not
[Music]
is there anything else you want to show
me
[Music]
what
I am Diana famous Kira daughter of
Hippolyta in the name of all that is
good real wrath upon this world is over
[Music]
um yep that's not gonna work please put
the sword down it doesn't go with the
outfit at all what is your mission to
stop the war what war the war to end all
wars I cannot stand by while innocent
lives are lost be care